the longest journey that I have ever
taken that was in 2002 I was only 19
years old it was the first time I had
ever been on an airplane and the first
time that I had left my country Rwanda I
had to move thousands of kilometres away
to follow a dream a dream I have had
ever since I was a child and that dream
was to become an architect that was
impossible at the time in my country
there were no schools of architecture so
when I got a scholarship to study in
China I left in my life and my family
behind and I moved to Shanghai it was an
amazing time
this country was going through a major
building boom shahi my new home was
quickly turning into a skyscraper city
China was changing world class projects
were built to convey a new image of
development modern striking engineering
marvels were going up literally
everywhere but behind these facades
exploitation of huge numbers of migrant
workers massive displacement of
thousands of people made these projects
possible in this fast paced development
also contributed significantly to the
pollution that is haunting China today
fast forward to 2010 when I went back
home Tyrande there I found development
patterns similar to what I saw in China
the country was and still is
experiencing its own population and
economic growth the pressure to build
city's infrastructure in buildings is at
its peak and as a result there is a
massive building boom as well and this
is the reality across the entire
continent of our
and here's why by 2050 Africa's
population will double reaching 2.5
billion people at this point the African
population will be slightly less than
the current population of China and
India combined the infrastructure in
buildings needed to accommodate this
many people is unprecedented in the
history of humankind we have estimated
that by 2050 we have to build 700
million more housing units more than
300,000 schools in nearly a hundred
thousand health centers let me put that
into perspective for you every day for
the next 35 years we have to build seven
health centers 25 schools and nearly
60,000 housing units each day every day
how are we going to build all of this
are we going to follow a model of
unsustainable building and construction
similar to what I witnessed in China or
can we develop a uniquely African model
of sustainable and equitable development
I'm optimistic we can I know Africans
who are already doing it
technogenic attacked coonley at the Emmy
for instance and his work in slums of
coastal mega cities places like macoco
in Lagos where hundreds of thousands of
people live on makeshift structures on
stilts on water without government
infrastructure or services a community
at great risk of rising sea levels and
climate change and yet people who live
here are examples of great ingenuity and
a will to survive Cunha and his team
have designed a prototype school that is
resilient to rising sea levels this is
macoco school
it's a floating prototype structure that
can be adapted to clinics to housing to
markets and that the vital
infrastructure this community needs it's
an ingenious solution that can ensure
this community lives safely on the
waters of lake us
this is Francisca ray he works in the
country where he comes from Burkina Faso
Kerry and his team have designed
projects that uses traditional building
techniques Karen is team working in the
communities have developed prototype
schools that the whole community similar
to every project in the villages of this
country come together to build children
bring stones for the foundation women
bring water for the brick manufacturing
and everybody works together to pound
the clay floors working with the
community Kerry and his team have
created projects that function better
with adequate lighting and adequate
ventilation they appropriate this
particular context and really really
beautiful as well for the past seven
years I have been working as an
architect at mass design group it's a
design firm that began in Rwanda we have
worked in several countries in Africa
focusing on this more equitable and
sustainable model of architectural
practice in Malawi is one of those
countries it's a country with beautiful
remote landscapes with high peak
mountains and fertile valleys but it
also has one of the worst maternal
mortality rates in the world
a pregnant woman in Malawi either gives
birth at home or shares to work a really
long journey to the nearest clinic and
one out of 36 of these mothers die
during childbirth in Malawi with our
team and mass design group we designed
the kizomba maternity waiting village
this is a place women come to six weeks
before their due date here they receive
prenatal care and trained in a nutrition
and family planning at the same time
they form a community with other
expectant mothers and their families the
design of the customer maternity waiting
village borrows from the vernacular
technologies of Malawi villages and is
built using really simple materials and
techniques the earth blocks that we used
were made from the same soil of this
site this reduces the carbon footprint
of this building but first and foremost
it provides a safe and dignified spaces
for these expectant mothers these
examples show that architecture and
design have the power and the agency to
address complex problems but more to the
point that we can develop a model of
effective solutions for our communities
but these three examples are not enough
300 more examples will not be enough
we need a whole community of african
architects and designers to lead with
thousands more examples in May of this
year we convened a symposium on African
architecture in Kigali and we invited
many of the leading African designers in
architecture educators on working across
the continent we all had one thing in
common every single one of us went to
school abroad and outside of Africa this
has to change if we had to develop
solutions unique to us rather than
attempting to turn ethically in to
Beijing or Lagos into Schengen we need a
community that will build the design
confidence of the next generation of
African Architects and designers
in September last year we launched the
African design Center to start building
this community we admitted 11 fellows
from across the continent it's a 20
month long design-build fellowship
program here they are learning to tackle
big challenges such as urbanism and
climate change as Khun Lee and his team
have they are working with communities
to develop innovative building solutions
and processes as Kerry and his team have
they are learning to understand the
health impacts of better buildings as we
at Mass Design Group have been
researching for the past several years
the crowning moment of their fellowship
is the real projects that they design
and build this is Raheja primary school
the project they designed they immerse
themselves in the community to
understand the challenges but also
uncover opportunities like using a wall
made of local volcanic stone to turn the
entire campus in a space of play in
active learning they evaluated the
environmental conditions and developed a
roof system that maximizes daylight and
improves acoustic performance the
construction on a primary school will
begin this year
and over the coming months the African
design center fellows are going to work
hand in hand with their hair community
to build it when we ask the fellows what
they want to do after the African Design
Center fellowship what pepa from South
Africa said who also introduced this new
way of building into his country so he
plans to open a private practice in
Johannesburg zanny wants to expand
opportunities for women to become
engineers before joining the African
Design Center she helped start in
Nairobi an organization to bridge the
gender gaps for women in engineering
fields and she hopes to take this
movement across Africa eventually the
whole world Moses from South Sudan the
words newest country one stop in the
first polytechnic school that will teach
people how to build using local
materials from his country moses had to
be determined to become an architect the
civil war in his country frequently
interrupted his architecture education
at the time he was applying to join the
African design center we could hear
gunshots going off in the background of
his interview call but even in the
middle of the Civil War
Moses hangs on to this idea that
architecture can be a way to bridge
communities back together you have to be
inspired by this fellow's belief that
great architecture can make a difference
on how the future of Africa is built the
unprecedented growth of Africa cannot be
ignored
imagine Africa future cities but not as
bad slums but the most resilient and the
most socially inclusive places on earth
this is achievable and we have it the
talent to make it a reality but the
journey to ready that talent for the
task ahead like my own journey is far
too long for the next generation of
African
native leaders we have to shorten and
streamline that journey but most
importantly and I cannot stress this
enough we have to build their design
confidence and empower them to develop
solutions that are truly African but
globally inspiring thank you very much
[Applause]